[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 l'hebdo ravi de vous
retrouver pour un tour de l'actualité de
la semaine dans le département
tout de suite les titres de ce vendredi
26 avril le grand débat national s'est
achevé le président de la république a
fait ces annonces ce jeudi soir lors
d'une conférence de presse à l'elysée
le point sur les grandes orientations
plus de cinq mois après le début de la
crise des gilet jaune
emmanuel macron a donc pris la parole ce
jeudi soir le temps des conclusions est
arrivé pour parler avec nous en plateau
béatrice piron député de la 3e
circonscription des yvelines projet de
ferme photovoltaïque portrait de pascal
zimmermann atteinte de la maladie de
parkinson ou encore des idées de sorties
comme chaque vendredi
coup d'oeil sur l'actualité de la
semaine mais avant de débuter ce journal
une triste nouvelle le secours populaire
a perdu son président julien lauprêtre
est décédé à l'âge de 93 ans à la suite
d'une chute pour laquelle il avait été
hospitalisé il avait rejoint le secours
populaire en 1954 il avait rencontré à
plusieurs reprises il est bénévole des
yvelines le monde et caritatif français
a perdu un grand combattant contre la
pauvreté politique
à présent la conclusion du grand débat
national du président de la république
emmanuel macron a présenté plusieurs
mesures lors d'une conférence de presse
ce jeudi à l'elysée
objectif répondre à l'injustice au
manque de confiance et au sentiment
d'abandon des français elle les
précisions avec nikola d'andry un cap
plusieurs orientations et d'abord sur la
question du pouvoir d'achat sujet au
coeur de la mobilisation des gilet jaune
l'impôt sur le revenu de 15 millions de
foyers devraient bénéficier d'une baisse
de 5 milliards d'euros dès 2020 les deux
premières tranches seraient concernés
pour les retraités le président de la
république a décidé de ré indexer les
retraites inférieures à 2000 euros par
rapport au coût de la vie
autre point abordé les pensions
alimentaires impayées directement
prélevée par la caf et pour financer
notamment la diminution de l'impôt sur
le revenu et
nouvelle macro a lancé quelques pistes
j'ai donc demandé au gouvernement de
mettre en oeuvre cette baisse d'impôts
en la finançant par la suppression de
certaines niches fiscales pour les
entreprises la nécessité de travailler
davantage et des réductions de notre
dépense publique
nous pouvons faire aussi bien en
dépensant moins et donc supprimer nombre
d'organismes inutile à propos des
institutions emmanuel macron souhaite
renforcer le statut des mers pas de
référendum d'initiative citoyenne voulu
parler gilet jaune mais une
simplification du référendum
d'initiative partagée avec un seuil fixé
à un million de citoyens
accompagné d'un droit de pétition sur
les sujets locaux
enfin une refondation du conseil
économique social et environnemental
avec l'intégration de 150 citoyens tirés
au sort
le président de la république a aussi
annoncé un nouvel acte de
décentralisation des politiques de la
vie quotidienne attribué spécifiquement
aux collectivités pour répondre au
manque de services publics en zone
rurale des maisons france service
regroupant notamment la caf ou pôle
emploi devrait être déployé dans les
cantons enfin emmanuel macron souhaite
réorganiser les services de l'état dans
les collectivités en envoyant des
fonctionnaires parisiens sur les
territoires financement calendrier mise
en oeuvre toutes ces mesures seront
précisées par le gouvernement en
revanche le vote blanc et le retour de
l'impôt sur la fortune seront écartés
alors que ces points ressortait
majoritairement du grand débat national
+ 2 5 mois après la crise des gilet
jaune le temps des conclusions est
arrivé pour en parler avec nous en
plateau bat respirons député la
république en marge de la 3ème
circonscription des yvelines bonjour
bonjour on l'a vu dans le reportage les
personnes qui ont participé à ce grand
débat notamment dans les yvelines
demander la reconnaissance du vote blanc
emmanuel macron est contre écoutez la
question du vote obligatoire qui est
souvent revenu
je ne retiendrai pas cette option j'ai
un moment été tenté par cette option j'y
ai beaucoup réfléchi et je ne la retient
dre pas je ne la retient dre pas parce
que au fond la crise de nos démocraties
est aussi une crise d'efficacité de
capacité à prendre les décisions
alors on peut avoir des projets dont
aucun ne nous plait totalement à une
élection mais on doit choisir
parfois le moindre mal ou le mieux
possible et ce choix est important parce
que dans les moments difficiles de la
démocratie il faut prendre des options
et il faut choisir et je sais une chose
c'est que quand on vit une période
difficile
blanc ça ne décide pas blanc c'est
l'agrégation d'hergé mais refuse c'est
trop facile
une réaction va tu respires on m'écoute
et mot cg et j'avais eu des propositions
dans les débats locaux de ma
circonscription notamment sur le vote
obligatoire comme en belgique
j'avais entendu cette revendication je
crois que le président comme l'a dit lui
aussi a longuement réfléchi on n'est pas
passés là dessus mais par contre c'est
vrai que pour le vote blanc on a du mal
à comprendre et ne peut pas faire une
reconnaissance du vote blanc sans
ajouter en fin de compte
en complément parce que qu'est ce qui se
passe si ce n'est que des votes blancs
si les votes blancs sont majoritaires on
n'aura pas un président blanc donc après
c'est une mécanique complémentaire à
définir on n'est pas tous d'accord non
plus sur ce qu'on va prendre comme
action dans ce cas là faites dorer
galant
gt gt contre la reconnaissance du vote
blanc je trouve que c'est trop compliqué
à prendre en compte parce qu'il faut
bien choisir un président au moment où
un autre donc c'est laisser une porte
ouverte et une facilité pour certains de
dire je ne fait pas l'effort de choisir
est je vote blanc mais qu'est ce qui se
passe rien pour voter encore deuxième
fois une troisième fois
nous venons ce n'était pas efficace
aurait peut-être éventuellement plutôt
envisager tech le vote obligatoire
autre revendication des gilet jaune à
mais pas seulement la mise en place d'un
référendum d'initiative citoyenne le
président a dit non également on
constate beaucoup de divergences entre
ce que souhaitait les gilet jaune et la
restitution du grand débat non pas tant
sa divergence il ya une divergence sur
ce point là mais c'était pas le point
initial les premières réclamations des
gilet jaune au mois de novembre c'était
les taxes sur les carburants c'était du
pouvoir d'achat et c'était des impôts
l'heure n'est pas le leur et qui est
arrivé un tout petit peu après je pense
plutôt poussé par certains mouvements
politiques
il existe des jeunes
le rip qui va peut-être être mis en
place qui va être assouplies donc il n'a
jamais été testés n'a jamais été mise en
place déjà essayons cet aspect là qui
existe déjà dans la constitution et le
fait que les citoyens veulent plus
participer à la vie politique mais déjà
ils ont participé en débattant cette
année je pense qu'il y ait débat il y
participeront à travers plusieurs
instances du coup il y aura des
personnes tirées au sort ils pourront y
avoir des référendums donc locaux donc
je pense qu'il ya en s'orientant vers de
plus en plus de participation des gens
et sept-îles c'est bien mais c'est un
autre moyen de participer qu'avec le
rich et concernant la baisse des impôts
la baisse des impôts dont je crois que
donc ça a été clairement annoncée donc
15 millions de français de foyers du
monde 15 millions de foyers ça ça
représente beaucoup de personnes qui
auront une baisse d'environ 10 % environ
en moyenne 300 euros
donc c'est du pouvoir d'achat donc je
pense que c'est un petit complément par
rapport aux mesures qui avaient déjà été
donnés au mois de décembre et qui va
dans le sens de plus de pouvoir d'achat
pour les travailleurs autre point
beaucoup de citoyen déclaré renoncer à
leurs droits car les démarches
administratives sont souvent difficiles
et parfois trop compliqué et la création
de maisons france services et pour
pallier la désertification des services
en zone rurale rompre l'isolément
alors sans langue on l'a beaucoup
entendu et
on entendait dans le grand débat en
disant qu'on quoi il y avait un risque à
supprimer des fonctionnaires de
supprimer ou de fermer en fin de compte
des services décentralisés et d'éloigner
en fin de compte les services publics
des citoyens et donc je pense que ça va
être quelque chose d'apprécier
d'appréciables ca va un petit peu en
phase ou un accompagnement aussi de tout
ce qui est le défi numérique qui est
déjà bien entamée de pas beaucoup
d'administrations et aujourd'hui des
français qui sont un petit peu donc en
marge de cette évolution et qui ont des
difficultés à se connecter à pouvoir
aller sur leur site de cafu leur site
d'impôts ce qui est quand même très
pratique pour les gens qui ont leur
connexion et donc ça permettra d'avoir
des gens en service dans les petites
villes un petit village dans tous les
cantons donc une maison service français
service je pense que ça va être attendu
et espéré
emmanuel macron a annoncé hier plus de
fermeture des hôpitaux ou des écoles
sans l'accord du maire d'ici la fin de
son quinquennat
mais concernant la restructuration des
services comment ça se passe sur le
terrain
sait on avait déjà annoncé donc agnès
buzyn a déjà annoncé donc un plan
important sur les hôpitaux de proximité
donc une volonté de réinvestir et
d'investir à nouveau dans des hôpitaux
de proximité pour pour contrecarrer un
petit peu cette désertification médicale
dans le monde rural
donc les hôpitaux ne devront plus ferme
et je pense qu'il n'aura plus qui
fermeront sauf si c'est vraiment des
bâtiments vraiment trop délabré et un
accord avec la population et avec le
maire par contre c'est vrai qu'il ya
toujours un risque
il faut quand même aussi s'adapter dès
fois à la demande locale à la capacité
donc est déjà des régions de france où
on pressent qui aura peut-être besoin de
fermer un service maternité
s'il n'ya pas d'anesthésistes s'il n'ya
pas sur place un pédiatre ou aux
obstétriciens
on ne peut pas maintenir une maternité
et on va pas maintenir un médecin à
spécialistes sur place il y à une
naissance par mois alors qu'à d'autres
endroits en france où
manque aussi de médecins donc je crois
qu'il faut être raisonnable l'important
est qu'ils aient un hôpital de proximité
qui puisse traiter les urgences qui
puisse être traitée la population locale
avec des fois des services de gériatrie
des services adaptés à la population
locale même si parfois on peut perdre un
bloc opératoire ou de maternité autre
point important la transition
énergétique
un des axes principaux du grand débat le
président a annoncé il y à la création
d'un conseil de défense écologique
par ailleurs 150 citoyens tirés au sort
vont intégrer le conseil économique
social et environnemental ses citoyens
auront notamment en charge de réfléchir
sur les questions écologiques pour la
fondation hulot
la déception est grande elle s'attendait
à des mesures concrètes comme la fin des
véhicules diesel et essence en 2030 ou
encore à la fin du glyphosate
en 2020 on l'a vu des citoyen donné l'
alerte des lycéens se mobilisent chaque
vendredi pour lutter contre cette
urgence climatique mais le gouvernement
continue d'attendre
n'est-il pas trop tard pour réagir non
je pense pas que le gouvernement attende
on continue la feuille de route et
c'était prévu donc le glyphosate donc on
en a longuement parlé
on a une loi qui est déjà passé l'année
dernière donc qui établit comme quoi il
n'y aura plus de glyphosate donc en 2021
2020 exactement je sais plus vers 2025
2020 voilà début 2021 pour les véhicules
diesel donc la loi l'homme sur les
mobilités donc elle doit être présentée
au mois de mai dans l'hémicycle donc le
texte est déjà écrit donc n'y avait pas
besoin de faire une annonce sur ce sujet
là ça va passer dans dans les deux
assemblées
c'est prévu être voté donc est ce que ça
sera 2030 2040
alors là c'est après aux parlementaires
j'irai de trouver la juste mesure pour
cette interdiction des ventes de
véhicules de gasoil je crois qu on
poursuit par contre comme vous disiez on
a besoin aujourd'hui d'écouter les
citoyens en a besoin aujourd'hui de une
politique plus participative et je pense
que ce soit aussi bien que des citoyens
plus s'impliquer et que leurs idées
soient mises en place également à 1,5
million de français ont contribué à ce
grand débat mais rapportée à 47 millions
de français inscrits sur les listes
électorales
il y à un fossé peut-on vraiment parler
de grand débat béatrice piron oui je
pense que tous les gens qui avaient
besoin envie de s'exprimer ont pu le
faire que ce soit dans un cas isolé ans
dans une réunion ou sur un site internet
moi j'ai reçu beaucoup de courrier j'ai
même reçu des courriers manuscrits des
gens qui m'ont envoyé leur contribution
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas de connexion
internet et je crois qu'on a essayé de
prendre en compte un maximum de
l'expression des gens qui avaient envie
de s'exprimer
si après les gens ne souhaitent pas
s'exprimer ou si ce sont déjà
représentés par une idée quelque chose
qui a été déposée par à par leurs
familles leurs voisins on n'a pas besoin
toujours de répéter ce que son voisin a
déjà dit donc je pense que c'est c'est
quand même représentatif lundi un
séminaire gouvernemental se tiendra pour
préciser les orientations du président
de la république
merci batterie spire ont d'avoir été
notre invité je le rappelle vous êtes la
députée lrm de la 3e circonscription des
yvelines
merci merci beaucoup on passe tout de
suite au reste de l'actualité de la
semaine
[Musique]
dernière ligne droite pour le projet de
ferme photovoltaïque à triel sur seine
une enquête publique est en cours si ce
projet est validé par les autorités les
habitants pourront bénéficier de cette
électricité verte reportage d'aurélie
rose et patrick jacques de dixmude d'ici
2021 cette ancienne décharge devenu une
friche naturel pourrait accueillir une
ferme photovoltaïque de 20 hectares
situé en bordure de la départementale
190 42500 panneaux solaires permettront
de fournir de l'électricité à l'ensemble
des habitants de triel sur seine
on a été il ya des années des années une
des premières communes à être une
commune
verte on a toujours continué dans cet
esprit a travaillé à faire du tri
sélectif et donc du panneau solaire
l'énergie renouvelable c'est aussi notre
notre souci il y a dix ans le projet
avait été abandonné en raison de
l'instabilité du sol
une enquête publique a été lancée au
début du mois d'avril
objectif permettre aux habitants d'en
savoir plus sur cette ferme
photovoltaïque c'est bien c'est pour
l'écologie c'est pour le climat donc
c'est bien que des avantages on va
remplacer des déchets par une quelque
chose de favorable à la à la nature dans
le contexte actuel c'est pas quand même
pas une mauvaise idée plutôt qu'une
décharge
enfin sur une décharge on pourra rien
faire donc donc change tout c'est une
bonne solution aujourd'hui une
alternative écologique intéressante pour
la société urbasolar a été choisi pour
aménager ce parc solaire estimé à 18
mégawatts
en plus d'être une zone inconstructible
le site possède également un autre
intérêt on a un poste de transformation
relief à proximité donc le raccordement
il faudra tirer du capa entre 3 km ça
c'est un avantage pour nous dans les
prochaines semaines le dossier sera
entre les mains de la creuse la
commission de régulation de l'énergie
c'est cet organisme indépendant qui est
chargé de valider ou non le projet
verdict aux alentours du mois de
septembre
la maladie de parkinson est une maladie
neurodégénérative caractérisée par la
destruction des neurones à dopamine
tremblement au repos ou encore lenteur
dans les mouvements sont les principaux
symptômes
en france deux cent mille personnes sont
atteints de cette maladie
j'ai suivi une de ces personnes elle
s'appelle pascal et zimmermann c'est le
portrait de la semaine
pour ses 50 ans le diagnostic est tombé
pascal souffre de la maladie de
parkinson
ça fait neuf ans que je sais que c'est
la maladie mais
très simplement ça a débuté une dizaine
d'années avant troubles du sommeil
rigidité dans ses mouvements traits du
visage qui se fige et perte de l'odorat
ont donné l alerte
j'avais un odorat extrêmement développé
et tout d'un coup plus de doha je me
suis aperçu aussi que quand je marchais
j'avais un bras qui ne balançait plus et
puis surtout les tremblements alors là
je cliquais n'importe où j'arrivais pas
à mettre la crème sur le visage enfin à
touiller à salade
les difficultés du quotidien amplifie
les symptômes de la maladie de parkinson
pascal à son échappatoire
streiff accents team les symptômes de la
maladie
le bruit de l'eau le bruit de la cascade
se feront du bien
imaginez les pieds pas prêt pas
peut-être des petites branches qui
craquent sentir les odeurs et se laisser
imprégner d'une énergie de renouveau la
pratique d'une activité physique douce
aide à contrôler et l'anxiété des
malades et à diminuer leurs symptômes
lâchez les mains et puis observer
observer comment vous vous sentez elle
est arrivée bien sûr avec cette douleur
avec ses raideurs et puis à la fin de la
séance
c'était vraiment flagrant là elle elle
tombait à cet instant pascal prend de la
dopamine toutes les trois heures elle a
ce qu'on appelle des périodes on off
quand je suis en vain de doses alors là
je vois la maladie qui a peu surgi à
grands pas et alors j'ai l'impression
d'avoir les boulets aux pieds
d'être complètement enfermé dans une
cage pascal ne se renferme pas sur elle
même elle reçoit ses amis une
préparation s'impose
le tout c'est pas trembler les douleurs
provoquées par la maladie peuvent
modifier les rapports avec l'entourage
la proportion de personnes atteintes de
dépression est beaucoup plus élevé avec
la maladie de parkinson que la moyenne
c'est quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de
volonté et je suis très admirative de
voir avec sa maladie tout ce qu'elle
fait elle recule la maladie elle l'a
fait reculer l oubli même si la maladie
se rappelle à elle se confie à des
personnes attendent des mêmes maux
france parkinson propose des rencontres
pour échanger et s'informer
pascal participe aux réunions de
rambouillet à 59 ans elle est consciente
que cette maladie neurodégénérative a
bouleversé sa vie ne dit pas je ne sais
plus faire face
il faut dire aujourd'hui il arrive à
faire ça persévérante
elle profite de chaque instant au
maximum ne sachant pas de quoi demain
sera fait déterminée elle pratique la
danse en ligne depuis trois ans un
excellent exercice pour les personnes
atteintes de parkinson
la line dance ici on apprend vous avez
vu des chorégraphies avec des pas qui
font entre 32 et 64 temps par côté par
murat répéter donc pour la mémoire c'est
énorme et ça pour le cerveau je pense
que c'est vraiment important pour ces
personnes-là pascal s'est fixé un
objectif réussir entièrement sa
chorégraphie malgré la maladie est
envoyé sa performance à france parkinson
le château de dampierre a rouvert ses
portes une nouvelle balade au coeur de
la vallée de chevreuse à faire pourquoi
pas en famille marylène iapichino et
nicolas d'andry ils ont emprunté une
voiture est au beau milieu d'un parc
forestier de la vallée de chevreuse la
nature se laisse écouter on est au coeur
de la campagne et donc du coup
quand on sait et oiseaux si on a de la
chance est arrivé quelques fois où aller
chevreuil pas cela et puis on essaie de
vue sur le château isolé au calme le
château de dampierre a rouvert son parc
au public depuis le 30 mars il offre une
balade familiale sur un territoire à
l'histoire royal l'histoire c'est celle
à famille de luynes qui devient duc de
chevreuse et qui à partir de ce
moment-là veut construire le château
avec jules hardouin mansart qui permet
bien après cette famille d'imposer son
pouvoir sur cette vallée de chevreuse et
d'y recevoir la cour de versailles
un aménagement permet aujourd'hui des
balades en calèche en rosalie mon
voiturette de golf et même sur l'eau sur
les pas de louis 15
imaginez des chaloupes qui depuis le
château sont arrivés avec des
embarcations de part et d'autre et une
grande fête a eu lieu ici
et donc c'est ce pavillon sur l'île est
vraiment extraordinaire
alors il faut qu'il soit restauré
évidemment mais il est vraiment
extraordinaire parce que c'est cette
petite folie posé au milieu de l'hiver
mon petit grain de fantaisie
surprise dans les hangars un ensemble de
calais des voitures hippomobiles sont
conservées cinq d'entre elles sont
exposées au public en attendant
l'ouverture prochaine d'un musée dédié
donc du coup on a exposé et bien
découpés de gala des calèches jusqu'au
break de chasse qui était tout le train
hippomobile pour la vie quotidienne des
ducs et duchesses de lune au xixème
siècle le château de dampierre était
fermé depuis 2016 les yvelinois peuvent
de nouveau investir c'est patrimoine de
1749 c'était toujours un moment en fait
très privilégié parce qu'on passe et
voir en ce moment à un pique-niqué
ensuite à jouer au football donc j'ai
vraiment des souvenirs vraiment réussi
de nouveaux souvenirs qu'il se construit
dans ce parc en attendant l'ouverture du
château lui-même ses travaux de
rénovation sont actuellement à les tuer
[Musique]
êtes vous prêt pour l'avant match c'est
la nouveauté du stade de france visite
guidée sous forme d' escape game vous
partirez à la découverte des coulisses
du stade mythique des bleus à travers à
l'avant match d'une équipe
professionnelle de football et
découvertes avec deux confrères de via
grand paris dans les vestiaires du stade
de france c'est l'agitation entre les
maillots demba p6 d'un lloris
petits et grands sont à la recherche
d'un 10 pour déchiffrer le code qui leur
permettra au final d'entrer sur le
terrain cette visite comme les autres
c'est l'avant match
la nouveauté 2010 neuf du stade de
france c'est un jeu en immersion au
stade de france qui permet en fait de se
mettre dans la peau d'un d'un joueur de
match en passant par les vestiaires des
arbitres par la salle de presse des tirs
joueurs après si tout se passe bien il
ya même un petit entraînement et éviter
des radars en tribune présidentielle
sachant qu'il ya un peu des gens qui
sont pas très gentils qui veulent nous
empêcher de gagner du coi par découvrir
qui comment pourquoi et se défendre
contre ses ennemis
l'enjeu est important battre l'équipe du
sc loser qui tentera par tous les moyens
de barrer la route du fc mis sur eure
pour gagner il vous faudra aller dans
des lieux inédits du stade comme les
douilles des arbitres et déjoue les
pièges des adversaires le tout sous le
contrôle énergique
le coach a mis qu elle est bien
maintenant
mais fo faut pas saisie n'est pas faux
quand même bossé faut travailler
correctement
voilà toujours avec le sourire avec
énergie moyens inédits et ludique de
faire découvrir le stade de france
avant-match tente de plaire à toutes les
générations
nostalgique de 98 ou jeunes sportifs
connectés car pour cette plongée
immersive votre smartphone sera un outil
essentiel pour avoir tous les indices
résultat une visite qui semble réussie
pour tout le monde c'était bien mais le
stade le stade il est grosse impression
en fait je m'attendais pas à voir autant
de choses et j'ai été surpris par
exemple en voyant la tête du vestiaire
arriver au milieu de ce stade c'est
assez magique et on a envie évidemment
les les sportifs qui ont la chance
d'évoluer là dessus avant match
l'expérience immersive est attestée dès
maintenant
comme chaque vendredi nous vous ouvrons
les archives de tv 78 et en avril 2002
nous suivions l'élection présidentielle
avec la qualification au second tour du
front national
[Musique]
fait inédit dans les annales
universitaires les doyens des facultés
d'île de france ont appelé les étudiants
à s'opposer au front national en votant
jacques chirac
les étudiants n'ont bien sûr pas entendu
cette consigne pour se mobiliser ce
matin à l'université versailles saint
quentin on s'activait en vue des grands
rassemblements du 1er mai des étudiants
qui sont partis sur les différents sites
de l'université parce qu'on était un
moment ce matin qui sont partis aussi
faire le tour des lycées de saint
quentin en yvelines pour ben
informer les lycéens les étudiants la
jeunesse en général mobilisent parce que
je suis vraiment vraiment dégoûté ce qui
s'est passé et je pense que ça va faire
réagir la france parce que je crois que
tu vois qu'il ya trop de personnes sont
inconscients de ce qui s'est passé
des forums de discussion sont organisés
élèves et professeurs débattre des
questions qui animent le débat politique
de l'entre-deux-tours confesseur leur
soutien est unanime et la consigne de
vote des présidents d'universités selon
justifié c'est évidemment un petit peu
extraordinaire mais on vit dans une
situation tout à fait extraordinaire
quand il ya le feu dans la maison ben
faut jouer les pompiers donc il joue les
pompiers et je pense qu'ils ont raison
c'est ce qui confère la pop
y'a pas d'autres choses à faire ils ont
raison de le dire ce mercredi ils seront
nombreux à manifester le rendez vous est
fixé à midi devant le bâtiment vauban
induit en courant
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est la fin de ce set 8 l'hebdo passer
un excellent week end
[Musique]